you can't always say I don't do this or
I'm not this because you don't know
what's gonna happen next if I get
passionate about something and there's
no stopping me if you're really honest
about the music are you really doing it
to make money I mean how can you put
money value to to music need motivation
watch a top 10 with pity's nation
she's Gwen Stefani and here's my take on
her top ten rules of success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one live in the moment one of the big
lessons that I've learned in this year
is just that you can't always say I
don't do this or I'm not this because
you don't know what's gonna happen next
like nobody knows that's one of the
blessings of being a human we don't know
the future we don't know what's gonna
happen we know what's around the corner
but we just trust in the moment so
that's why I've been really trying to
like exercise that like moment like this
is happening right now I don't know
what's gonna happen so I'm not gonna
worry about that rule number two be true
to yourself for business I tend to lean
on people that are really talented and
passionate about business so I just
basically find people that I think are
really smart around me that that's what
they do and I never want to do anything
that is not authentic to what I really
believed because the point for me is not
the final outcome or the the money in
the bank it's really about expressing
myself and being true to my whole
aesthetic and who I am
and what I love nothing's easy I just
happen to be lucky enough to have work
that I love to do but I think that
having a name can sometimes be against
you especially in business because
people want to recognize you for what
they know of you and they don't want to
say oh she could do that too and you
have to prove yourself sometimes
starting a brand outside of what you
people know you for is is a struggle and
I think the only way to do it is to be
real about it and to be pure about it
and to be be honest and true to yourself
and so that's really what my whole thing
has been I mean there's been so many
opportunities to slap my name on
something that could have made me a ton
of money but at the moment it didn't
feel right so I never really do anything
that doesn't feel right in my heart rule
number three discover your gift
it went from because my brother was the
main songwriter
when he sort of was you know he didn't
really want to do it anymore and then we
broke up all of a sudden this fire came
out of me like it was one after another
I just was writing them and I didn't
even know I could do it and it was just
all of a sudden I went from being my
whole existence was like being in love
with my first love and like having my
best friend my boyfriend to like this
powerful position of writing these songs
and it became it was like this passion
to be able to be a songwriter to do
something you know it wasn't really good
at school I was going to college I
didn't know what I was gonna be I just
knew that I wanted to just have kids and
be married and you know but none of that
was working out so it was kind of for me
it was an incredible time cuz it was
like I had just discovered who I was in
a way through this music and who knew I
mean I think everybody was surprised
like that I could do it you know like I
would I would be calling him up going
you got here this long I wrote about you
it's so intense you know he'd be like
wow that's amazing
rule number four listen to your inner
voice the secret to her longevity is
carefully picking her projects I just
try to listen to that inner voice of
what is what did what is it telling me
like what do I want to do next I have to
genuinely care about it because
otherwise I'm quite lazy girl like I
swear
it just wants to lay in bed and eat
pizza and then eat M&Ms afterwards like
tag I'm that girl that's my that's
pretty much like 85% of who I am so if I
get passionate about something and
there's no stopping me also if you want
to learn from other successful women
entrepreneurs checking my 2:54 girlboss
series it's free the link is in the
description below you might want to get
honest with yourself I can study doing
this via billionaire or do this do you
really because you can make it happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
when I'm not joyful I look at what
happened well number five don't do it
for the money with the current state of
music so much beautiful amazing stuff is
coming out of it and yeah it sucks that
we're in a place where you know the
value of what you do is less now but if
you're really honest about music are you
really doing it to make money I mean how
can you put money value to to music I
mean of course like part of me is gonna
stand there and be like pay me the money
like I made the music this is my job
this is my gift I need to get some kind
of compensation because I have to live
for me when I'm making that music I'm
making that music to save myself to
express myself number six
follow your passion I know Interscope
was really in some ways they were really
supportive because they they really let
us grow and and they didn't you know
they didn't give us a stylist they
didn't try to tell me how to dress they
didn't none of that stuff it was really
organic the way they did head they were
like you just sit in the studio write
songs and you know we're gonna maybe
hook you up with a few people we think
he should work with us producers and and
the one thing we're going to do for you
is we're gonna buy you an 8-track
recorder that you
and have in your garage and you can try
to write songs and record them and we
would sit in there and we would write
songs and we would record songs and we
were all going to school we were all
working and that's what we did for fun
and we were never gonna make it and we
weren't doing it to try to make it we
were doing it because we were passionate
about it and we really did want to after
that many years of being a live band we
wanted to give the fans that we did have
music that was recorded and so it was
more like the goal to be able to be
signed to have the money to actually
make a record not so much to make it
because we weren't gonna make it because
we were making the music we were making
and it was the Grunch
right phenomenon happening how just a
girl gonna get on the radio this it
wasn't gonna happen so that was never
our I don't feel like that was our goal
our goal was to just to finally maybe
become a recording band and have music
that our fans could actually listen to
rule number seven turned pain into
creativity Stefani's 13-year marriage
just singer gavin rossdale ended in a
very public way this past fall but she
found love with a certain co-worker and
you can almost feel it happen as you
listen to her new album which she says
is all about healing and new beginnings
you've gone through a lot I have gone
through a lot but I feel like you have
to be grateful for that because if I
didn't do that then I'd wouldn't have
this and yeah to be grateful for all of
it taking the pain and turning it into
such creativity how did you channel that
I think that I just I felt like I was so
um I was so like kind of I felt like
stir I forgive me what by the words oh
my god I was embarrassed and I was I
felt like wow I can't go down like I
don't want it this is not who I am I'm
not gonna fail I had to make something
good out of it so I tried to write
because I know that that was my gift and
I was like I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
make this into music this year has been
mind-blowing
just can look back and go wow there was
a time where I didn't know how I was
gonna get through it it was really hard
to get the courage this it was important
for the wind because it's another one of
those times in your life where a
situation shows you what you're made of
taking the pain trying to make something
great out of it is what I really tried
to do like please let me just let me use
my talent let me just be that person
again it happened and it worked right
now I'm feeling a little bit like roughy
on the top of the steps of the hands
that void Oh like rule number eight find
who you are what did I do consistently
to get to this point and I think that
would be to be really clear about Who I
am and to go with that and not try to be
something that you're not you'll stick
out because we're all very very
different but yet all the same I think
that you know it's weird because in the
early days like everything was so home
made there was nobody telling us what to
do or how to do things nobody telling me
how to put my makeup on or how skinny to
be or what costume to wear what song to
write and I think that was a really
important thing because it means that we
were really ourselves
I think the inspiration just came from
like the creation you know like to be
able to create and express yourself I
truly think people need to like just go
inward and go what what do I like Who am
I you know there's been people that I've
been fans of like Julie Andrews or
Emmylou Harris there's a band called
fishbone that we used to go to all their
shows and of course but I honestly say
that like you know really it's all about
like finding who you are rule number
nine find confidence is the confidence
level good do you feel nervous about
bringing new music into this world after
not having done it for so long I think
it comes with the music you know it
determines everything about how you feel
and I think when we made this record the
last few years we've been making this
record it was like we were also on the
same page about the kind of
I mean what is the point at this point
put a record out unless we think it's
gonna be like amazing in our favorite
record we've ever done and like our best
work and like you know we we had to
really fight to make this record it
wasn't like we just you know glided into
the studio and had luxury of time it was
really like it was just passion and the
strive to want to really make it and
have to fight for it so with all that
hard work behind us and to actually know
what the record is because we're
addicted to it and listening to it in
their cars and like written just about
ready busting to share it there's
there's a confidence that comes with it
because and it's not it's more about
like knowing how much we love it and
knowing the people that are that are
actually supporting us and that they're
waiting for and they're excited force
and those people that give us a
confidence the people that have given us
this life and supported us those those
fans I guess that kind of gets it just
gets you riled up it's exciting to share
it you know and rule number ten the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
support others
[Music]
smile
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
now got a special bonus kit from Gwen on
how to define success for yourself that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions you watch the video
now it's time to take action here we go
question number one what can you do this
week to support someone else number two
what pain of yours can you turn into
creativity and number three what is your
inner voice telling you that you should
listen to for me like to have a long
career it's mind blowing like I don't
understand how I mean how I get to keep
going it is so incredible so for me
success is really just having a career I
mean success is to be able to have
opportunities still and what's really
important is the journey so if I'm still
on my journey then I'm successful
if you want to learn how to make it as a
musician check into video they're right
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I want to tell you the most
important piece of information that
applies not only to your musical career
but your entire life and I've seen it
work and I've seen it not work